so i was revisiting the nle chapa album
top shot up it's basically hip hop that
makes you want to rob your own house and
that's kind of the vibe you want when
you're about to do a workout so i was
trying to get in the zone
but every single song he'll throw in
some ridiculous metaphor to
food the whole album is filled with food
bars and it kind of threw off my whole
day
but i realized rappers rap about food a
lot if i just play through my music
library
i bet i can go three whole days eating
all of my meals
only with foods that are mentioned in
rap lyrics
i'm from the bay area so you know i mess
with e40 and he does this thing where he
kind of just smashes words together into
a line
no regard for the number of syllables
doesn't even make a sentence
he just goes like digital scale green
eggs and hams
yams candy yam spam damn loaded
my cheese peanut butter and jam if we're
taking the green eggs and ham literally
i can just mix the yellow egg yolk with
some blue food coloring spam for
breakfast is such a bay area filipino
thing love that
and then i got some canned yams which
aren't candy yams but they're sitting in
a sweet syrup so that's close enough
this is from one of his early songs
called the slap and it's one of the
reasons why we say
this slaps or that slaps e40 was one of
the guys on the song snap your fingers
by lil jon
but he also had the songs function and
tell me when to go he's basically
carried the whole hyphy movement ever
since 2006 which was after mac dre
passed away rest in peace
i'm excited about this pb j sandwich
because my entire life i was allergic to
peanut butter and then all of a sudden i
somehow outgrew it so now i'm addicted
to them
wasn't really sure where to use the
digital scale that e40 mentions
it's probably just for weighing portion
sizes for food and literally nothing
else now it's lunch time and we got some
lyrics from the rapper lil pump
who blew up back in 2017 because of
gucci gang but i honestly really liked
his first self-titled album it's been
downhill from there but he still drops
lyrical gems
like this i'll need you i'll need school
i'll pop beans
i'll need food lefres costs a bentley
coop drop tanzans in wonton soup
this is really exciting because i
haven't had wonton soup in like over a
year because it's not really my go-to
take out food but now there's a chinese
restaurant that's back open down the
street and i've been wanting to try it
i don't think people traditionally eat
wonton soup with
xanax though let alone ten zans which
seems way higher than the typically
prescribed dosage so we're gonna skip
that part
okay so for sure i want to do a drake
bar for dinner because
he always tries to be really cool and
super serious but then he hits us with
lines like this
yeah how's that for real you toyin with
it like happy meal
all right so for sure we're going to
mcdonald's but i'm not buying myself a
happy meal so we got to get another
mcdonald's bar i have to mention the
most famous mcdonald's line by far
it comes from kanye west in his song
with jay-z where they're in paris or
something and it goes
that should cray that's cray ayna j
what she ordered fish fillet the fish
fillet was just okay
would have been better with ketchup but
jay-z said six deuce every time i never
had the heinz
57 can't catch up to mines so i just
can't do it
now stay tuned and we'll start with a
line from eneli chapa i might just
ko that perk up in my fago run up on me
wrong
turn his head into a bagel so mr chapa
doesn't really specify what to eat the
bagel with but i did listen to the song
broccoli
where dram wraps in the second verse
couple summers later i got paper i
acquired taste for salmon on a bagel
with the capers on a square plate
at the restaurant with the why you got a
stair face
this rounds out the classic lox bagel
sandwich which is a really interesting
flex to show you've made it you know
usually it's like a car a rollie no
nine dollar sandwich the song broccoli
has such a
2016 college freshman energy
i love it all right for lunch we got the
cardi b line from the song best life
i'm like big pop mixed with tupac i'm
like machiavelli
you need some lil caesar's pizza i'd be
hot and ready
so machiavelli was the name for tupac
shakur's alter ego
hot and ready is basically the little
caesars pizzas that are like
five or six dollars they're sitting in
an oven in the front and they're warm
all the time so you can just walk in
grab one
pay leave you're done in like a minute
now that this concept is actually in my
life because of this video
it's kind of dangerous because knowing
me i can easily just
inhale like 2 300 calories in one go
for dinner we're doing the classic lil
wayne song six foot seven foot the whole
song is full of quotables but
there's this one line in the second
verse paper chasing
tell the paper look i'm right behind you
bit
real g's move in silence like lasagna
okay so the g is technically not silent
because that's what gives it the
sound but it's funny so we'll let it
slide i don't even own a baking dish
so i got this lasagna that's frozen and
microwavable and honestly it's pretty
good
so good morning again i was just
listening to a rick ross track
it was a pretty deep cut but he raps
about some really heavy
serious stuff catching a case and going
into county jail the police raiding his
parents home
someone shooting someone else in a beef
and then hooking up with the victim's
sister
and then he drops this line shot him in
the kitchen heard over a bowl of cereal
this deeper than rap i guess a box of
cap and crunch gets you deeper than that
got the captain crunch right here and he
has another song called 16 where he says
now i get 100 racks for the 16 waking up
to turkey bacon and my fit queen
i'm using this line because add some
protein to the meal and i'll just let
those get crispy
and some close-ups just to show you it's
crispy and then we pour the cereal in
the only civilized way to do so which is
before the milk
this breakfast doesn't really work
unless you do the signature rick ross
grunt with it
he always wraps in this really beefy
voice that sounds
like how his beard looks great way to
start the morning
before lunch i was listening to some
doji cat and one of my favorite songs by
her
is called juicy i listen to the original
version without tyga
and in the last verse she says ate my
fish like tekamaki like a side of me
with sake
so i put it in my mouth and suck it out
like edamame
that's kind of a lot but i do like
takamaki i also got some edamame right
here and some sake now i'm barely gonna
drink any because
three sips will turn my face into a
cherry after those lyrics i'm not
putting these in my mouth and i don't
know the proper technique for using soy
sauce
but i can hear someone typing in the
comments right now that it's not
whatever i'm doing now for the last
dinner we got a deep cut from smoke perp
and it proves that you can make any
lyrics sound hard as long as it fits the
triplet flow i get the cheese fettuccine
alfredo he came with a bag and he left
with a halo
that was part of his hook on the song
fettuccine alfredo by rapper tto kt
yeah i don't know him either but smoke
perp had an interview with sway and
15 minutes in the camera pans over to
the right and tt okt
was next to him the entire time and they
tell him to freestyle and he just goes
off
smoke perp also has another song audi
which is one of his most famous ones and
he says
whipping jeff hardy in the kitchen
counting and wrap up the chicken
there we go there's my permission to
make this chicken fettuccine alfredo
it was a little bit chunky so i went
back and mixed in some pasta water and
it turned out pretty well
all right so that's pretty much it for
now let me know down below if there's
any lyrics that i missed or if you want
to see another video like this thank you
for watching and i'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
you